let's move boys
good work soldier ascension seven
fifteen one 2
19 7 25
6 13 6
7 15 14
0.
[Music]
i understand what's going on around you
you are in a state of war
and you have precious little time to
save yourself
is a slow process which we call active
measures
the first stage being demoralization
it takes from 15 to 20 years to
demoralize a nation
the next stage is destabilization
what matters is essentials economy
foreign relations defense systems
the next stage is crisis
with a viral change of power structure
and economy period of normalization
this is what will happen in the united
states if you allow all these schmucks
to
put a big broader government in
washington dc
we will promise lots of things never
mind whether the promises are fulfilled
or not
the time bomb is ticking every second
the disaster is coming closer and closer
the danger is real
this war was a lie
years of blood just delight the fuse of
a secret war
decades in the lake
my fellow americans the nuclear conflict
could well be mankind's last
we want to make this a more peaceful
world
five days ago we acquired intel
soviet agent perseus is in play
if he's active something big is gonna
happen
something that could shift the balance
of the cold war
let's go find the [ __ ]
mr president is the threat real
yes sir we believe it is give mr adler
whatever he wants
i know you won't fail us
pre-order digital copy and get early
access to the open beta and instant
access to the woods operator pack in
modern warfare including warzone
so
you